again I'm bringing back an idea from the
non-spoiler portion because I love
hearing about how things evolve because
many think you go in with a script and
it's perfectly refined and cannot change
so can you give me an example of a seed
you planted in season one that might
have seemed meaningless but now it pays
off in season two and you could go like
aha like that was there all along but
then I want the opposite as well
something you never plan for that we see
in season two but it needed some
finessing because you hadn't prepared
for it in season one
it's a great place yeah that is a great
question I can't believe that came out
of my mouth
very well stated I mean we could we
could talk about the journal a little
bit maybe
um Jackie's uh you know or I would love
to hear about the journal I still have a
burning question from season one about
the journal I mean it's just like I was
gonna bring up and I this is maybe you
know what I will not give the context
yet because it is spoilery but there is
a moment at the keg party in
um the pilot where Natalie is tripping
and she sees Misty and that is something
that we planted very early on that will
pay off later
yeah yeah because that's a great
question but I was just like I I mean
like I know there are things but you
know it's just like walking into the
bookstore I mean like things that are
changing that's what yeah I'm kind of
curious about
um oh oh oh wait it was things that uh
uh that we knew would pay off and then
things that we didn't know would pay
something in season two that you had to
plan for in season one and it took some
finessing to fit in right yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah because that I mean like
that does strictly happen all the time
uh uh like you know even throughout the
season even throughout a single script
like you know like I think a big part of
our process is sort of being a kind of
open to the level on which like these
things are happening like kind of
subconsciously and you know and it's
just like you are kind of making
decisions because you're like following
what seems exciting and then that kind
of all of a sudden you're just like oh
this all came together
um in this way that like I don't know
that I could have planned it or we could
have planned it and so I know that
happens all the time I know it happens
all the time
yeah it's easier to remember the things
that we planted because we did it
purposefully yeah like the we there's a
throwaway line in
um
which episode was it it was it was in
season one and it was I think episode
[Music]
11 somewhere around there there's a
throwaway line where Travis is playing
Solitaire or trying to play Solitaire
and Natalie tells him that there are no
queens in that attack and that was a
plant very much for this season okay
yeah that's a good one I like that one
yeah I like that one
how about if I kind of switch that
question to being on set and your actors
because it does sound like you're able
to recognize when they do something
special and you're willing to go with a
change that they might make happen so
what scene changed the most from script
to screen because of what happened on
set during filming it's another good
question well I don't know I don't know
if this is a change but I can't tell you
this
um you know we did script this idea that
Natalie would get adult Natalie would
get to such an abject place that she
would try and do Coke and then try and
do it off the carpet you know and get
like just the little uh you know
corpuscles of coke that were left out of
the fibers of the carpet but I think
what surprised all of us is the way in
which Juliet really went for that I mean
when we saw the footage it was operatic
and uh and pretty terrific I mean we
could have showed like a three minute
version of her slithering down the bed
and like getting really into it and we
obviously chose like what we felt were
the choices bits but we didn't know it
was going to be that kind of iconic I
think when we wrote it it was scripted
pretty simply yeah it was it was this
big yeah it was in the script you know
Natalie trashes her hotel room looking
for the remainder of the coat and then
she went for it yeah yeah and I mean
like I you know I don't think this is
necessarily like um the most exciting
answer but like I think a lot of the
change that happens
um as a result of the way the cast
starts to uh kind of inhabit the
characters is like
like uh not something you can exactly
like articulate or plan for it's just
that there was a shift where you know uh
when we were pitching this idea or kind
of riding the pilot you know like you
hear the characters voices in kind of
your head and then um after they get
cast and you know the cast is playing
them you then start to hear their voice
and like that and you know to see them
as well and like that has a tremendous
kind of impact because it's just like uh
the Acoustics of the kind of ideas are
changed so everything sounds and feels
very differently who changed the most
then after after the character was cast
who changed the most I feel like I feel
you know I feel like maybe Melanie
because you know I feel like
in uh my head and it's even hard to
remember specifically the sound of
Shauna because I kind of obviously like
you know she was like drawing from
um you know the lines that are written
there but so like it's not quite a
Cadence thing but uh but like like the
amount of uh uh like uh there's a thing
that like a Melania is so great at with
kind of Rhythm that like like um I heard
somebody I kind of describe it as like
the bouncing ball for like a a kind of a
song uh I'm on like a a TV uh or it's
like it's hitting the words it's like
she's like just sort of like bouncing
through them where each one is doing
like a slightly different thing in this
way that's just like kind of amazing to
watch and so yeah
um I think that like hearing that's like
oh the like a like a resonance level of
this line is going to be exponentially
wider uh um as a result of her handle
it's also Faith you know you have to
cast the right people for this reason
like I think we all want to explore the
the subtlety of relationships and the
the nuances of human behavior right but
if you have actors who can't do subtext
then you've got a big problem so you
start writing toward their strengths and
luckily we have like a very strong cast
across the board and so you can start
having a CNB not just about one thing it
can be about three things and often the
thing it's really about is in the
silences and you know and you can trust
that will work yeah I will show you
proof most of my questions for the cast
is about reaction shots
right they they all do it they're all so
present which is so great because
sometimes actors you know will wait for
their moment on screen but right you
know for instance Samantha henratty the
number of times that we would be in post
and watching footage and watching scenes
and notice what she was doing in the
background which would not be scripted
you know it's just like Misty there and
she is so in character all the damn time
that we would find that we would have
these great cutaways that just because
Misty was being Misty in the background
yeah I mean sometimes Samantha will come
up behind the monitors like oh you're
not really Samantha right now you're
Misty still so I need to talk to you
like this
I'm gonna end with a question about
episode six because the the birth
sequence is just really something else
was the plan always to have the baby die
or did you ever consider how things
might play out if that had gone a
different way the plan was always to
have the baby yeah yeah and I mean like
we certainly
I mean like I think we consider kind of
everything that was always the plan for
sure yeah you know we kicked the tires
on it we made sure that that felt like
it was the right decision but you know
we really I I do think that we also
Infuse that it would have been tricky
had we gone a different way because we
really infused that that death and that
loss into Shauna's relationship with
Cali and her disconnect and her sort of
estrangement from her daughter in our
minds has always been a result of that
loss and so I think we would have had to
really reframe that relationship in a
way that might not have worked for us
right what about exploring that
situation via the vision that Shawna has
why was it important for you to let
young Shauna get a taste of what it
would have been like before ripping it
away from her well because I mean well
like you know a huge thing that we like
often like try to do or really I kind of
want to do is to like give the audience
as much possible like like like like a
visceral Taste of uh the subjective
experience of kind of the character and
so you know to just say well she lost a
baby and you know that hurts her right
like but like how do you express that
and give people a handle on how to feel
it well you show what she lost and like
you give a taste of that of you know
like all that that could have been and
so like yeah that's why we did it what a
crushing way to do it's too effective I
could keep you guys here all day I'm not
allowed congratulations thank you so
much